heartiness oh please where you am late
but you late - hi my name is Diane
Guerrero and I'm a BuzzFeed today and
we're doing the best friend test and
that's Jackie Cruz don't like Todd Ruby
I don't know buddy
okay one two three ha ha that's good
what's that that's good
dammit that - I said eating salt and
vinegar chips but that's good I mean
she's more right than I I know this -
you know better than I do
I would probably make coffee she's right
[Music]
now don't show yet I'm not I'm okay
whatever you soon say you could move
that she says it a lot
yeah but [ __ ] is classic this is like
daddy's exact word but I do I say like
Hans to me after every other word no I
do it she doesn't know me I was oh wow
Wow
me I thought we were going deep don't
copy I know you can't cheat on this Ted
kisses listen like for each other I
don't even fight
she's a fashion Beast I said braiding
hair do you spell braiding like what the
hell have you ever married I cool well I
would love for you to come from I have a
love for you to give me all right you
know I could cornrow I had no idea
[Music]
[ __ ] yours is wet wait long
hahaha Bobby Fred I like you a copyright
but that seat that's best what you hate
about me I didn't know well I did get a
mint today where nothing is loving her
best friend I didn't see how we were
right here but we're not here to Wow
next question today my god let's just
get one please guide or else this is all
of you have I haven't gotten one yet
listen oh I got it oh wait hold on can I
see what was some funny here and Jackie
we were supposed to show it together at
the same time well you're the one who
shows it first why don't you do one two
three our outfits
yeah but this was hilarious when you
were trying to smize and she didn't know
how to it was like smizing
number two taking down come on let's get
on nine okay I'm trying
hit it can't can we like no you know
what my guilty pleasure is alright go
what sleazy fuzz burger just cuz you
love to wife I do I do but that's not
like my I'm not guilty about it I'm very
proud I would never shut up food yeah
you see me like scarf down yeah go
through Martin the soda and Alyssa yeah
but you're gonna feel guilty after alone
I didn't know she fall guilty feel
guilty
she loves them candies yo oh we need to
write it down
Jesus I'm so sorry I forgot but don't
write that down because that's not it um
okay that's it if you don't get this and
our friendship is freaking over all
right I already you already wrote to my
go for the doughnut
sure I don't even have that many
doughnuts listen do I eat yeah I just
like ones in a room like she eats him in
secret how am I supposed to know oh come
on
taking your hints No okay wait can't you
know okay ready
ahh pretty woman I know you're right I
love Selena but pre I know you're it's
your favorite movie I know okay she knew
that worried oh you know this I do all
right ready yeah we gonna friends and
kiss dad yeah it's okay it's still
celebrity
[Music]
angelic vocals oh my god you're oka the
allowable deny them what is it the
coolest person ever yeah people know
you're super cool but I feel like people
don't think that I'm as cool no you're
cool it that's a secret that's a secret
okay this is bad
what is that oh really
where is it no actually you send me this
one hell is that these are the hand
click oh yeah donor blood goes doesn't
it we should stick tag we don't know
anything about each other I don't I
don't think we could be best friends
you ruined our life earned our
friendship well I definitely learned a
lot today about things that I should
have known well I just yeah we just need
to like start like paying attention to
each other yeah yeah because the little
things are the most important yeah and
it's like if we have to work on a
relationship that's what we learn
absolutely thank you I'm so thankful for
BuzzFeed for giving me the opportunity
thank you for giving me